in this morning's eye on earth signs of
environmental damage are everywhere but
sometimes those signs are very hard to
see tiny nearly invisible pieces of
plastics called micro plastics are
making their way through our ecosystem
and the results could be devastating CBS
this morning Saturday co-host Michelle
Miller is here Michelle good morning so
what our science is finding they are
trying to figure it all out scientists
say every year worldwide more than 300
million tons of plastics are produced
half of it is for single-use but around
8 million tons of it end up in the ocean
where it's consumed by ocean life and
eventually passed on to humans before
dawn on the Oregon coast marine
biologists are on the hunt for what's
nearly impossible to find micro plastics
5 millimeters or even smaller here the
tide pools are covered with mussels and
welts and that's just what dr. Suzanne
branders team wants to collect like this
individual
pure ocean water flows through these
shellfish but microplastics good stuff
we're seeing on average a couple of
pieces of suspected plastic and in each
and each animal branders lab at Oregon
State University is part of a worldwide
microplastics research effort that has
found few places untouched they're being
found in Arctic ice it's not as if there
are people dumping plastics off the
iceberg it's coming from global air and
ocean circulation we live in a plastic
world at the Scripps Institution of
Oceanography dr. Jennifer Brandon found
more evidence deep in the ocean floor
off Santa Barbara and these are all
sediment cores her sediment samples date
microplastics back to the 1940s we can
look at how has plastic changed in the
sediment and it gets there in many ways
these fibers are coming off fishing rope
but a lot of them are coming off our own
clothes
so as you're washing your clothes
they're washing down the drain they're
too small to get caught at the
wastewater treatment plant and they're
washing right out into the ocean these
micro plastics seem to be in everything
I mean tea bags you name it clothing and
the majority of the clothing of very
synthetic we drink out of plastic water
bottles we use straws and all of those
things break down and the smaller pieces
on the road there's trouble too
tire particles from discarded tires from
tires from where the car is being driven
along the road there are small particles
wearing off the tires and getting into
the water sheds are getting into the air
even a study found seven trillion micro
plastic particles pollute the San
Francisco Bay each year and researchers
are seeing an impact we do know that in
aquatic animals that there are suggested
effects on things like immune response
and respirations we see some effects and
in oysters that are exposed they lay
fewer eggs does it harm us
we don't know yet what the concern is
that these microplastics are getting
into our seafood they're getting into
our water so we know we're ingesting
them but we don't yet have a measurement
of what the effects might be and while
America waits for more studies to be
done before taking regulatory action the
European Union is already taking a stand
in March it voted to ban single-use
plastics 13 months from now those
plastics alone account for 70% of the
plastic litter found on beaches
throughout Europe so they're not waiting
it's a big political issue though the
Trump campaign is actually selling
plastic straws with Trump's name on the
side and their fundraising offers that a
lot of people don't want plastics banned
yeah you know we obviously there's the
obvious stuff you see like plastic bags
that wash up on the beach this is so
alarming when you see all this others
there's so much really alarming is if
they don't know what what the impact is
go yeah yeah might be okay might not
it's in your clothes yeah should these
do just walk around naked because I'm
trying to attract viewers I don't want
to scare people I need to leave my
clothes on Michelle thank you very much